I am delighted to be here tonight and
when mrs. Kramer called me to say would
you do this I said listen I have to tell
you a very interesting and funny story
about it's a mad mad mad mad world how
many meetings were there at the studio
to determine how many Mads there were
and in 1963 the movie came out
November 7th I was living in New York I
was 15 years old fifty years ago that's
coming November and this will get funny
but it was my brother Richard who's here
and I reminded me of this story and I
actually had forgotten it is that my
father had died in October of 1963 it's
he was always doing stuff like that and
and it was obviously a very hard time
for us and then the movie was coming out
and he was a comedy freak
my dad turned my brothers and I on to
all the great funny people during that
time and earlier in New York and local
stations and we had Ernie Kovacs and
Phil Silvers and and we had all of these
great incredible people Sid Caesar and
call Reiner who'll be out on the stage
in just a minute and all these amazing
people and now here was this movie and
most of them were in it and so the month
went by and then Judaism you have a
certain amount of time to mourn which is
forever and and my brother said to me
don't you remember we took my mother to
see the movie and you know something she
hated it I've debated whether to tell
that story or not now we loved this
movie and we thought it was hilarious
and what was great about it was apropos
of the all-star game tomorrow that's
what this movie was for us it was an
incredible all-star game with the
greatest people in the world the people
who made me want to be funny all in one
movie
and and like I said I was a junior in
high school so I always wanted to do
this I was want to perform and I
performed by myself but also one of my
closest friends and I had a comment were
a comedy team his name was Joel Robbins
and Joel and I did Laurel and Hardy
routines and we did all kinds of funny
stuff together we were in shows together
and we just we just loved being funny so
when the movie came out and I'd see it
we got to go see this we got so we saw
it again and then we said we got to do
something so at the age of 15 Joel and I
formed a ticket agency company and we
sold 150 tickets to the members of the
junior class of Long Beach High School
Long Beach Long Island we got our
principal dr. Norman Schwartz widen to
let us go he gave us the day off from
school
we got $3 round-trip tickets on a Long
Island Railroad special fair we had
buses meet us at Penn Station we went to
the theaters saw the movie and when when
it worked out that I was going to do
this thing tonight
now I called Joel I said fifty years
later you want to see the movie again
and he's here tonight and it's maybe the
best part of it where are you Joe there
he is
you got a bigger hand than I did okay
well we're gonna move this along cuz the
movie some of you may remember is is
nine hours long and it will be shorter
than some satyrs but maybe not all